so yeah not the video you were expecting
yeah me neither
but so basically the title says it all I
turned for honor into a very disgusting
and ugly looking game I wasn't even
really gonna do this video but then I
was searching through YouTube and came
across this video by basically homeless
he's a rainbow 6 youtuber and basically
he basically played Rainbow six on the
lowest settings possible even after
turning it down into low in game he went
into the files and just screwed with
everything so I thought hey this might
be a good idea I'm dumb enough to change
the game settings and screw with
everything a foreigner to the point
where it even might be game breaking or
unplayable so I did this video is either
gonna do very good or very bad it
doesn't really matter because this was a
lot of fun to record this so first I
hopped on the PC since that's the only
way you can do this
also I don't play a lot of PC so excuse
the fact that I'm rep one and have no
characters except a couple unlocked I'm
mostly play console but I turned my game
on to the highest settings possible
before I basically tore up my game and
lost on my framerate and it looks pretty
damn nice
sadly my framerate was at 30 FPS which
if you don't know framerate is very
important in fighting games especially
in for honor so I put it back down to
low settings and honestly it's not even
really that bad there's minor
differences but nothing too crazy and I
usually play on low settings anyway when
I'm on PC so I can maximize my FPS in
game so this didn't really bother me as
much but I saw these handy-dandy buttons
called aspect ratio and render scaling
and this is where [ __ ] got interesting
first I want to apologize for the audio
on some of these parts throughout the
rest of the video recording the audio
with OBS [ __ ] it up so my bad I tried
to lessen it as much as possible in post
so let's hope it's not that bad so this
is the width aspect ratio on and nothing
seems too crazy I did change the
settings a little bit so we have no I
have no clue what is going to happen I
could see the black bars though so this
hopefully isn't that bad okay I mean
it's alright yeah it's pretty trash Mike
okay so guard stance is definitely I
know for this game for this mode
here is very bad I can barely see my
screen as it is in the what after I was
done giving myself a loss of vision I
decided to see if I could tweak with
some of the settings internally going
through the files and whatnot credit to
the low spec gamer for explaining how to
accomplish this a video in the
description below if you actually want
to do this yourself but basically to
summarize I [ __ ] up for honor to where
I thought I flashback to the days of
runescape I mean you can't tell me this
doesn't look like runescape it's
honestly an exact replica of the game
the characters look like clay and it's
absolutely disgusting yet somehow
comical for me I don't know why I found
this super funny and even the textures
on the flames look absolutely disgusting
to the point where they're just pixels
and not even actual flames and even the
minions in the game are just a solid red
color and there's nothing they're not
jagged or rigid or anything they're just
completely smooth and it looks like
someone melded them together with clay
but then I thought to myself I have the
shitty clay graphics from runescape and
the low settings from in-game what would
happen if I put them together okay so
now we're gonna load up both of these
together that being the clay runescape
looking graphics and then the shitty
aspect ratio I mean it's not bad and me
come on it's it's not that bad okay I
was wrong this is really bad
as you can see combining the powers of a
paperweight to smoosh my screen down to
a very small size on top of the fact
that with the clay material of the
characters making it look like runescape
and all this other type [ __ ] my game was
entirely [ __ ] up all of the pixels in
to get in the games and all the minor
details just turned into big black or
big square pixels it was so weird even
to the point where the explosions were
just a few white pixels to show what
would weight should be debris it was
absolutely disgusting and on top of that
there was barely any blood when I was
killing people it was basically just
little mini bits of red pixels that were
squares and it looks so disgusting
foreigners all about that gruesome type
of combat especially with the executions
and doing this just made it feel so
unappealing to me
other than that though there were some
other things I tweets with as well but
there wasn't really anything noticeable
differences though well while I was
doing this I had a great idea if it
works in multiplayer than this
has to work for story mode and sure
enough it did
[Music]
as you can see the campaign looks just
as bad as the multiplayer did and what
is confusing to me though is that every
character had the clay look to it but
for some odd reason your berserker
teammate you had was kind of normal in
the Viking campaign you obviously had a
beserker type teammate and his head had
normal textures but the rest of his body
was clay which made no sense and I
thought it was only the berserkers but
then when you fight Civ which is a
little bit a few missions in the
beginning she's actually fully clad out
in texture so I don't know why this
specific AI is a little bit different I
don't know what's going on and it made
no sense to me whatsoever when I was
playing the weird textures actually
helped in a few scenes like in the
Nights campaign when the peacekeeper
ambushes you because you can clearly see
her since she didn't have the leaves to
hide behind and it makes a lot of the
areas a lot easier to see since the
textures got rid of most of the small
details on certain parts like fire and
it made most dark maps a lot brighter
which really helps if you have a low
brightness and you can't really see that
well so honestly it wasn't too bad and
even after all of this you think the
video would be over but no what if we
took the shitty graphics and got a bunch
of kills and made a montage no that
wouldn't be right it looks like crap and
nobody would enjoy it I mean come
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and this is the officially going to be
the end of the video thank you guys for
watching the whole thing if you got this
far I really do appreciate it this was
literally something I came up with on
the spot of course going off that video
that basically homeless didn't I was
like [ __ ] I might as well try to put my
own little spin on it I had a lot of fun
doing this I hope you guys did have a
lot of fun watching it like the video if
you did enjoy I really does help me out
subscribe if you're new by some odd
reason that you came across this video I
don't normally do this stuff too often I
know I'm mostly covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being leaks patches news all that stuff
mother new patch notes new leaks of
characters all that good stuff the
informational site a foreigner like the
cover this was something I thought I'd
throw in just for random because I
thought it'd be fun to do my two most
recent videos are gonna be on screen if
you guys haven't checked those out and
with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day really hope you enjoyed
this video and peace out